Traductor: Fabiola Santiago
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Cuántas personas se necesitan
para preparar una taza de café?
Para muchos de nosotros, solo es caminar
un poco y vaciarlo en nuestras tazas.
Pero este producto básico es el resultado
de un proceso que se extiende por el mundo
cuyo costo y complejidad son mayores
de lo que te imaginas.
Todo comienza en un lugar como
el pueblo remoto de Pitalito en Colombia.
Aquí, familias de granjeros talan
los bosques locales para hacer espacio
para sembrar ordenadas filas de cafetos.
Estas plantas, parecidas a arbustos,
comenzaron a domesticarse en Etiopía
y actualmente se cultivan
en las regiones ecuatoriales.
Cada arbusto está lleno de pequeñas bayas
llamadas “cerezas de café”.
Algunos frutos de la misma rama
pueden madurar en diferentes momentos,
por lo que es mejor cosecharlos a mano,
pero cada granja tiene su propio método
para procesar el fruto.
En Pitalito, los cosechadores trabajan
desde el amanecer hasta el ocaso
en alturas elevadas,
recolectando hasta 25 kg en cada turno
por muy bajos salarios.
Los trabajadores vacían sus bayas
en molinos con agua.
Estás máquinas separan
la semilla del fruto,
y las clasifican de acuerdo a su peso;
las semillas más pesadas y deliciosas
se van al fondo del molino,
se recolectan y serán llevadas a fermentar
en tinas con agua por uno o dos días.
Después se les quitará los restos
de fruta y se pondrán a secar.
Algunos granjeros usan máquinas
en este proceso,
pero en Pitalito las semillas se esparcen
en grandes rejas de malla.
Durante tres semanas los trabajadores
removerán las semillas constantemente
para asegurar que se sequen uniformemente.
Cuando los granos de café estén secos,
un camión los llevará a un molino cercano
con máquinas especiales.
Una sopladora de aire los separa
nuevamente de acuerdo a su peso.
diversos coladores los separan por tamaño,
y un escáner óptico los separa por color.
En este punto, expertos conocidos
como “catadores de café“
seleccionan muestras de granos
para tostar y preparar.
En un proceso llamado “cata de café”
evalúan el sabor, aroma y textura
para determinar su calidad.
Estos expertos les dan una calificación
y los preparan para su exportación.
Los trabajadores
llevan sacos de hasta 70 kg
de café secado y seleccionado
a contenedores de acero,
cada uno con capacidad
de hasta 21 toneladas de café.
Desde puertos tropicales, barcos de carga
tripulados por más de 25 personas,
transportan el café alrededor del mundo.
pero ningún país importa
tanto café como EE. UU.,
tan solo en Nueva York se consumen
millones de tazas cada día.
Después del largo viaje
de Colombia a New Jersey,
los granos de café llegan a los clientes.
Una vez que los trabajadores portuarios
descargan el contenedor,
una flotilla de camiones
transporta el café a un almacén cercano,
y después a una tostaduría.
Aquí, los granos se vacían
en una máquina tostadora
que los remueve mientras se calientan
en un fuego generado por gas.
Sensores monitorean el nivel de humedad,
estabilidad química y temperatura del café
mientras un ingeniero especialista en café
ajusta manualmente estos niveles
durante los 12 minutos
que dura el ciclo de tostado.
Este proceso libera aceites de los granos,
haciendo que las semillas sean más fáciles
de triturar y preparar
y dándoles un color café oscuro
y un aroma abundante.
Después del tostado, los granos se empacan
en bolsas de poco más de 2 kg
que son entregadas en flotas de camionetas
a cafés y tiendas por toda la ciudad.
El café ahora está tan cerca
que puedes olerlo,
pero necesita un poco más de ayuda
para el tramo final.
Cada compañía de café
tiene un jefe de compras
que selecciona cuidadosamente
granos de todo el mundo.
Equipos de logística
gestionan las rutas de entrega,
y valientes baristas de toda la ciudad
sirven este elixir cafeinado
a decenas de clientes apresurados.
En conjunto, se necesitan
cientos de personas
para hacer llegar el café a su destino,
eso sin contar a los que se encargan
de la infraestructura necesaria
para hacer este viaje posible.
Muchos de ellos reciben bajos salarios
y trabajan en condiciones peligrosas
y algunos ni siquiera reciben paga.
Así que, mientras nos maravillamos
de la red mundial detrás de este producto,
asegurémonos de no valorar
el producto final
más que a la gente que lo elabora.